good evening thank you for joining us on
game day i'm brian loftis i'm kirsten
joyce the big game night it is here my
friend we have been waiting and we do
have team coverage tonight for you from
the stadium to the traffic we've got you
completely covered but first a special
night made even more unique by the
mandatory vaccination requirement kate
houston joins us with a bit more on that
kate
yes well that alternate screening line
that spanned blocks earlier is now
completely over it moved very quickly
over the past hour not the case for
those mandatory vaccines we have this
line
over here to the right more towards the
stadium now this is taking a bit longer
it has made a little bit of progress
over the past hour but taking a bit more
time they do have to register get that
vaccine and then wait now once inside
fans can get their first or second dose
of the covet 19 vaccine they're offering
moderna and pfizer community ambulance
expects to administer a few hundred
vaccines today and anybody getting a
vaccine will be considered partially
vaccinated they do need to wear a mask
during the game
honestly i kind of let things go to the
last second and it's just convenient
that they set this right here so that
it's not going to prevent me from going
to the game
aside from vaccines this is also the
alternate screening area that i
mentioned this is for those who are
partially vaccinated those whose vaccine
is not supported by the app those who
were unable to upload their vaccine card
or for those bringing a 12 to 13 year
old that was unable to be added to the
app as well now thousands utilize this
today and throughout the weekend and
that line went very quickly back out
live this tent is only open until seven
o'clock so just under an hour now now we
have heard some reports of problems
connecting to that clear health pass
application
nothing substantial at the moment but if
we do have any more information we will
be sure to pass that along to you
reporting live outside of allegion
stadium kate houston 8 news now thank
you